This next story is just one of the most ridiculous
and stupid things that has happened
during the Trump presidency and that, I mean
it takes a lot for something to make that
standard. Donald Trump, yesterday during an
oval office briefing about Hurricane Dorian
held up an obviously doctored, weathered chart
that suggested that hurricane Dorian could
have hit or was on track to hit Alabama. Now
you might say, why is that something that
even matters to Donald Trump? This is all
to retroactively defend Donald Trump's tweet
from a few days ago warning Alabama about
the hurricane when Alabama wasn't at risk.
Trump holds up one of those big blown up images.
This is the hurricane track for Hurricane
Dorian and something looks weird on it. Take
a look and see if you notice it in the video.
If you're just listening to the show today,
don't worry. I'm going to describe it in detail
right afterwards.
We thought we'd give you a update on the hurricane.
We got lucky in Florida. Very, very lucky
indeed. We had actually our original chart
was that it was going to be hit hitting Florida
directly. Maybe I could just see that Kevin
there was going to be hitting directly and
that would have affected a lot of other states,
but that was your original thought. We were
going to hit not only Florida, but Georgia
could have going towards the Gulf. That was
what was originally projected and it took
the right turn.
So in the video when Trump holds up this image,
it looks like a sharpie was used to add in
a different different hurricane track that
included Alabama to provide cover for Donald
Trump. Having previously tweeted that Alabama
was in danger when it wasn't, which of course
resulted in mass confusion in the state of
Alabama. It resulted in weather services saying
Alabama is not at risk. You don't need to
evacuate. You're okay if you're an Alabama
other than obviously the completely horrible
social infrastructure, social service infrastructure
that exists. As far as the weather, I guess.
I mean you were okay in Alabama at the time.
This is not even remotely funny. This is extraordinarily
disturbed behavior. So now let's look at these
images in detail. This is the original map
that was published, the one from actual weather
people, and as you can see, the track simply
does not include Alabama as a place that's
at risk.
And then here is another version of the same
image that was held up by Donald Trump with
a black circle. Potentially a sharpie used
to draw a a draw in a section of the Florida
panhandle and pieces of Alabama, which is
totally and completely bogus. It happens to
be a crime to issue or publish an incorrect
or counterfeit weather report from the u s
legal code 18 us code subsection 2074 called
false weather reports, says whoever knowingly
issues or publishes any counterfeit weather
forecast or warning of weather conditions
falsely representing such forecast or warning
to have been issued or published by the weather
bureau. United States signal service or other
branch of government service shall be fined
under this title or imprisoned not more than
90 days or both. Just another crime under
the Trump administration. No big deal. There
are many. Now someone actually asked Donald
Trump during a subsequent media availability
about the word, uh, about a sharpie being
used for this to be drawn. And Trump just
kind of started stuttered and looked away
and said he doesn't know about that.
Alright, and that map, do you use those today?
It looks like it's almost like a sharpie.
I don't know. I don't know. That map that
you told us today, it looks like it's almost
like a sharpie. I don't know. I don't know.
Think
for a second. If the Trump administration
is willing to go this far for some, you know,
offhanded stupid, incorrect tweet from Donald
Trump about a hurricane and Alabama, how far
are they willing to go in other areas and
how far are they going in other areas that
we're simply not hearing about? Because every
day is lies and scandals and deception and
misdirection. The lengths to which this administration
goes to avoid simply owning up to a small
mistake. I mean, would it be that bad? Would
it be that crazy if we just had a statement
from Donald Trump? You know, I didn't mean
to alarm people that didn't need to be alarmed.
There was a point very early on where I believed,
uh, from the briefing I got that it was possible
that the hurricane was going to Alabama. That
possibility was no longer a possibility when
I sent the tweet didn't mean to, to, to, you
know, disturb people.
Uh, this was a very damaging storm regardless,
and we're, we're right, you, you could just
admit it, but there is something that goes
on in the guy's brain and it has spread like
a virus to the people around him where everybody
knows you can never back down. You double
down, you don't back down. In this time they
used a sharpie to double down. This is comically
insane, except it's not comical and it's not
actually insane and that this would be an
insult to insane people and I don't want to
do that. This is also not criminal genius.
This is struggling for what to call it. This
is malignant criminal narcissism and idiocy.
Maybe as the way that I would sum it up, and
Fortunately Fox News is not allowing this
to go unnoticed. Let's talk about that next.